is Ray going to turn to the dark side
will kylo Ren be redeemed will Snoke
return I need more Snoke in my life well
Princess Leia get the Royal send-off she
deserves and will episode 9 beat the
Avengers end game box office record
these are the top burning questions that
Star Wars fans have and we are going to
answer them right now
right Skywalker what does that mean as
it's always fun to have to have the
questions here with me today I've got
the director of fanboys Kyle Newman and
writer for The Hollywood Reporter
playboy an AV Club an all-around crazy
wolf East Angelo Monique to help me dig
in
that said I'm Eric Davis your host for
this new special aimed at unpacking some
of the biggest questions we have
surrounding the release of the latest
Star Wars film set to hit theaters this
December welcome to behind the movie
the rise of Skywalker before we dive
deep into the new film let's first
discuss where the last Jedi left us off
as the first order corners the remaining
resistance fighters in an old deserted
base on a planet crate Luke Skywalker
comes to the rescue by force projecting
himself into the middle of the
battlefield confronting and ultimately
fooling kylo Ren and his entire first
order army Luke ultimately sacrifices
himself so Rey and the remaining
resistance fighters can escape but right
before the credits roll we see a young
servant staring out upon the Stars and
as he briefly uses force powers to grab
a broomstick using it to mirror a
lightsaber we're left to wonder is this
the beginning of a new kind of Jedi and
[Music]
what would we call them instead which
brings us to the rise of Skywalker to us
it feels a different sort of end of an
era cos I wasn't around 42 years ago so
for people that have been fans that
whole time I guess it must be even
bigger but even for this five years I've
done it feels big to be finishing and
emotional easy you have no idea how huge
you get so emotional because it's so
personal to us it's almost like a family
member to so many people this entire
series we're starting to see new images
new trailers new clips but there are
still these burning questions that
everybody has that have not been
answered so let's answer them
now and you at home give us your answers
to this - in the comments as we're going
along I think this is the biggest
question that people have right now is
ready going to turn to evil ray are we
going to see her go to the dark side
first yes or no yes we asked Daisy
Ridley this very question and here's
what she had to say dude keep it a tight
lip but I think that was a reaction that
a lot of have a lot of us had let's
start with the hell no you are convinced
she's knock I think that's probably a
vision I think she's gonna be tempted
this whole movie by the dark side I
think they're gonna put our hero to the
test
and she's going to emerge victorious
this is nine films it's a culmination of
this huge saga and these generations of
characters and it's not gonna end dark
not she's gonna she's gonna overcome all
that adversity and all those challenges
and and stick with the light and there
is a moment in the Star Wars sort of
mythology when Luke has that in Empire
Strikes Back where he sees a vision of
himself in Darth Vader so they could be
nodding to that yes but no you have like
a both do Lance yeah so here's my theory
the entire saga is about bringing
balance to the force if Luke hadn't
brought balance to the force at the end
of his term then we're going to be
hopefully in part nine struggling with
how do we actually bring about balance
and I think in order to do that you have
to visit both the dark and the light
side my hope is that you'll learn about
the dark side but still be our hero in
the end I think she's gonna explore see
what that's about maybe get some Intel
but in the end she's still going to be
the hero Rey that we love still gonna be
hero but here's a sub question to that
are we gonna find out who her parents
are the last Jedi we're like your
parents were nobody I feel like it's
gonna be like the end of Annie we're
like Snoke hires like a couple to play
our parents but then they're like no
it's not your parents it really yes or
no no yes ish Joelle no we're not gonna
find it I don't want to know who raised
here don't you love the fact that Rey is
from nowhere that she just popped up and
like can still be a hero that leaves the
Aleksey maybe well understand why she
was left and what happened there but I
don't think that we need to get into it
her we we don't need to know why
everybody's connected to everybody by
the same bloodline I do you do need to
know and here's why this is the
Skywalker saga yeah and you just did six
movies and you can't tag three on at the
end if this person is tangental and
irrelevant so they're gonna have to find
a way to make it a commentary on that
mm-hm or I think she's gonna be somebody
I think she's probably and I said this
my first saw this trailer that she's
gonna take the name in spirit like
Spartacus okay so I think they might not
have her be who we expect but she's
gonna become an honorary Skywalker and
Skywalker will become a term for a new
type of force user that's why it's
called rise of Skywalker and not rise of
the skywalker it's I feel like it's a
new force user maybe it's light and dark
yeah like a little bit like a little bit
of both but I want sky one answers yeah
I think we need we do need some answers
maybe mom and dad don't need to know who
raised uncle is we can leave that let's
move on to the next question this is a
big one is kylo Ren going to be redeemed
so are we going to see kylo Ren turn to
the light side he's Han Solo's kid Ben
solo are we gonna see him at the DMV
sort of saying I want to change my
license now to Bend solo no hell yes
hell yes let's start with that one why
why because again this is the ninth
chapter it's the end
Star Wars is about hope he's fallen he's
reached rock bottom
he's disgraced his family I think he's
gonna come do something positive just
like Anakin did after he killed
everybody in the other ones buried in
there we've seen that he is a good
person he's just lost he's gonna
sacrifice himself and do something
positive in order to redeem the family
name and himself because not everybody's
lost not ever hope for everybody no
matter how how far down the road well
you make a good point I mean Darth Vader
who's like the baddest of bad ease at
the very end I feel like they could have
extended it to get a cup of coffee or
something finally standing there the Sun
the love unlocks him you know that's
familial love and I think that's gonna
be a big part of this you think he's
staying bad and that's it he killed Han
Solo thank you first of all
killed younglings yes and proved an
entire planet and mannequins redemption
happens so quickly there's a base
argument for like how much Redemption is
happening as you're dying you're sorry
and now you're God and you know I just
think that kylo at this point for and
from watching the trailer which
obviously isn't going to give us a lot
of details but he's a mask what looks to
be a very large army he's definitely
coming for them I kind of don't want to
see him redeemed and he's the bad guy I
love watching his bad guy he makes
really good bad guy we've seen him
betray ray already I think we're gonna
stay in that Lane and we're gonna see
our heroes find a way to bring some kind
of balance and hope in their storyline I
think it's a done deal to wrap for kylo
I want to see I want to see rain kylo
back-to-back again fighting alongside
each other and then I wanted to say kylo
and he's gonna be like no calm on board
I feel like I need a little bit more
Snoke in my life will Snoke return yes
sliced in half
but he's still coming back no his
physical presence I don't think we're
going to see you Snoke walking around or
giving orders smokes not a Sith so I
think that what's going to happen is
JJ's baby his creation of Snoke this big
bad villain II had that is now just
decimated very quickly we're gonna learn
more about him Gold robes tall guy lots
of power who is he is he the one who's
funding the first order I think we need
those details in order to wrap up his
storyline cosplaying as the Emperor but
Darth Maul from the Phantom Menace cut
in half comes back that is true but you
don't think he's gonna not coming back
but let's all just agree if a villain
gets unceremonious they killed from now
on let's call it you got smoked that's
know if you went out like a punk I think
they're gonna mention as maybe as early
as the opening crawl but I think there
needs to be some answers because he
wasn't just a guy running bureaucratic
guy running in the first order he had
force powers he could do things that
neither ray and Kyla couldn't foresee he
was powerful and I think there has to be
some type of explanation as to how this
person came out of No
well you can come back I work in Sam
Jackson and I told them that Darth Maul
came back he got cut he's like wait a
second
like your mace windu you can be back you
lost the hand and you fell out a window
and I think I put the idea in his head
that he should come back to Star Wars
well speaking of coming back
does Emperor Palpatine have something to
do with Snoke how is he returning in
this film if he died in Return of the
Jedi
I think force ghost because to me
there's something very eerie and and
everlasting about both Jedi and Sith
being able to come back and fight these
battles perpetually because isn't that
balance if it's never ending it's just
always kind of consistently a battle
between these two groups and also like
the Emperor's maybe the most horrifying
character in Star Wars if he can come
back from the dead that Wow awesome that
would be creepy if he even died though I
mean we saw him fall down that whole
sort of shooting out that lightning at
the end of Return of the Jedi what do
you think I don't think he ever died I
think he's been waiting waiting lurking
here in decades for the ultimate revenge
that's the perfect villain for the ninth
movie yeah he's been present throughout
all the other eight I think he's lurking
and I think you're gonna see him in the
flesh I mean if there's one family he
wants revenge on who is it all figured
out a thousand years of sift culminating
with him and then they totally pulled
the rug out from under him with love
I think family's a big thing and and I
think you're gonna see Palpatine with a
vengeance
Palpatine with a vengeance I like that
it's like look at the die-hard sequel we
never got so what do you think of holies
Emperor Palpatine how does he factor
into the film let us know he's a nice
guy in the country No moving on the next
burning question in this one I think is
a little bit emotional
well Princess Leia get the Royal
send-off that she deserves here's what
JJ Abrams's told us he had some
beautiful words about Carrie Fisher who
is in this film and let's see what he
had said the idea that she's not here
feels impossible
and she's she's wonderful in the movie
she was she was wonderful in life she
was very wonderful and they did use some
footage of Carrie Fisher from the force
awakens that they captured in order to
sort of complete her story in this film
first of all whoa whoa Princess Leia get
the Royal send-off that she deserves
I feel like this is a yes across the
pool yes how do you think she's going to
be in this film how do you think they're
gonna utilize her well Carrie Fisher
gave outside of Star Wars are these very
beautiful books that she's written a
great stand-up special and all of that
is a lot of advice to young women about
how to stand tall in their life and and
their decisions and I'm really hoping
the best sort of the wisdom that she
imparts to Rey as she leaves that we she
gives her you know the confidence and
the knowledge she needs to move on and
become the hero she needs to be I think
it's gonna be beautiful when we weren't
sure whether we were going to get hurt
in this film I thought that they did a
really solid job they gave her force
powers and last Jedi we saw her leading
and being command being a general and
worrying and all this stuff that I think
as a little girl I really craved in
early films
she's got power she's got status but
she's not really in charge of anything
and so see her fully in command and
leading her people it's incredible and
so I can't wait to see how they they say
goodbye to her it would make sense that
Rey learned what she did from Luke and
the last Jedi and then in order to
complete her learnings Leia kind of
comes in at the end and helps her
complete that do you think that's how
Leia returns and how do you think they
give her a proper send-off Leia Zoe's
been the spirited character she's always
had something to say I think she's gonna
go out the same way I think both she and
Luke will impart strength and wisdom
that's gonna help Rey through all the
challenges she faces in this movie it is
sad the Carrie Fisher is not here to
kind of see this through it because it's
been such a big part of her life I was
fortunate to work with her it was a
dream come true she was a class act and
I think it's gonna be good for fans of
all ages seeing this this character like
you said it's graduated from this young
girl fighting the rebellion to here she
has this resistance is gonna save the
galaxy yeah it's definitely gonna be the
most emotional point of this film I feel
that people could be like that's why I
have these tissues in my this moment
with with Leia how do you want to see
her story come to an end in this film
let us know in the
and before we dissect how much money
this thing's gonna make JJ Abrams had
some words about tying the entire saga
together let's see what he had to say we
have gotten a lot of flack for people
saying oh force awakens which is a
remake of new hope and you know wow that
was something that obviously was never
the intention it was about introducing
new characters using the old and there
is a natural sense in any hero's journey
of certain tenants that will come to
play we very much wanted to make sure
that that we were not somehow
inadvertently being so influenced by one
thing however this is a this the job of
this film is to be the end of nine films
so we can't ignore the fact that we come
from episodes one two three four five
six seven eight so it wasn't about
saying let's choose that one and let's
do a riff on that it was more how do
these stories culminate and that was a
good job this film for a lot of people's
make a lot of money we saw another big
finale this year with Avengers endgame
and how that turned out it is now the
highest-grossing movie of all time so my
final question for the two of you thank
you for joining me by the way my final
question does the rise of Skywalker beat
avengers endgame will we have a new film
being the highest-grossing movie of all
time or will it not no no but I hope it
does it can't beat it this year it's
coming out Julie Avengers had a second
run would you don't push it and propel
it over the top over time I don't think
we're gonna be able to tell that until
maybe two weeks out and we see you know
it's just a film we want to revisit six
or seven times that's gonna be the thing
that gives it the edge to become the
highest-grossing movie of all time it's
got to be you know repeat watches do you
think that it beats avengers endgame we
all go and bring our friends and
families and grandmas and cousins we can
do this it's gonna be hard to be
Avengers end game you had 20-plus movies
and you have this ten year hype cycle
however in the long run Star Wars is the
mythology of our time it is the most
important thing in pop movie culture and
I do think in 4050 years more people
with watching these nine films
than the Avengers cycle this is how much
all of the Star Wars films have grossed
a new hope very first Star Wars movie at
the top with 1.3 billion adjusted for
inflation where do we see the rise of
Skywalker falling on this list what do
you think I think it'd be really hard to
be a new hope and you hope ran for over
here and like I think eight months of
like books and comics and things to get
the kids excited and so no movie is
going to have a run that long that being
said I do think it's going to rival the
force awakens will it beat it I'm not
sure I think we're only at somewhere
between phantom minutes and force
awakens phantom medicine for some weeks
so it could be in that third position or
it could be right behind the Phantom
Menace Kyle where do you see it falling
here on this list funny I don't see the
Ewoks caravan of courage i watch caravan
of courage did not need unfortunately
did not make the list um I have high
hopes for film and I think it's probably
top three but it all depends on the next
two months and how much they connect and
hype let's see cuz the last Jedi the
last film is pretty down there on this
list so will it get into that top three
when you look at this list where do you
think the rise of Skywalker is going to
fall keep in mind this is it isn't the
end of the Skywalker saga is the pan out
I know I'm probably going 810 times I'm
bringing my children for the first time
to a Star Wars movie in the theaters
this is big it's anything that we want
to see like at midnight day that's what
I think and then and then I do like noon
the next day I don't know I can't why
the 3 a.m. god bless people that are
going at 3 a.m. to watch this film but
it is the kind of film that people are
going to be going those might be the
only seats that you get you gotta get
force awakens at 1 a.m. because then
they go fast so is the rise of Skywalker
going to beat Avengers end game at the
box office tell us what you think
throw out some numbers in the comments I
want to thank Kyle Newman and Joanne
Monique for hanging out with me my name
is Eric Davis enjoy the rise of
Skywalker loved' people this is it this
is the last one of the Skywalker saga
it's gonna be super emotional it's gonna
be super passionate for a lot of people
enjoy the show as many times as you see
it and let us know of course what you
think of the film in the comments